a été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solide alors qu'ils
étaient la résultante de 15 ans de
travail de fond fait par les analystes
rayon clair ils ont prêché la guerre
sainte et le problème c'est qu'on les a
trop longtemps laissé il ya eu un espèce
de déni de réalité et il a fallu grave
du bataclan pour qu'il y ait enfin une
reconnaissance générale de la situation
dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice madame
belloubet annonce la sortie en 2020 de
40 3 du à 10 140 avant fin 2022 sur les
531 incarcéré aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie de
ces individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
360 millions d'euros vont être affectés
à la lutte contre les violences mais
finalement ce n'est pas plus que l'an
dernier
au niveau des mesures ou nous annonce
beaucoup de choses qui existent déjà qui
ne fonctionne pas pour preuve son 38
victimes que le gouvernement ne nous
entend pas le gouvernement ne nous vois
pas un autre association en trois
mesures qu'on demande au gouvernement
c'est un les priver de liberté donc avec
le bras serait anti rapprochement de les
toucher au porte-monnaie les foyers
s'arrête à leur charge et 3 les priver
de leurs droits parentaux vous allez
continuez à vous battre
on ne va pas lâcher bien sûr
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour 1h30 d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenue évidemment à bonne
distance crise du coronavirus oblige une
émission essentiellement consacré à
cette crise en france et dans le monde
voici les titres
en france on dénombre 7630 de décès en
milieu hospitalier soit 541 morts de
plus en 24 heures annonce à l'instant du
directeur général de la santé qui
précise donc que ce bilan ne concerne
aujourd'hui que le milieu hospitalier et
exclut les ehpad pour le déconfinement
le conseil scientifique recommande
d'attendre la fin de la saturation des
réanimations et l'excès au matériel de
protection pour tous
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer demain
la pandémie pourrait entraîner la plus
profonde récession économique de notre
existence selon l'om c'est la france
elle y est officiellement entré le pib
chute de près de 6% au premier trimestre
précédent depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale l'europe mise en échec pour
trouver une réponse économique comme une
nouvelle réunion prévue demain
dans cette émission comme chaque soir
nous irons voir quelle est la situation
dans les autres pays du monde plus de 80
de 1700 morts sur la planète 60000 en
europe et au royaume uni l'état de boris
johnson s'améliore mais le pays déplore
la mort de 938 personnes de plus en 24
heures un record
la suède qui eussent vous le savez une
stratégie à contre-courant excluant le
confinement compte 100 décès de plus en
24 heures pires bilans quotidiens aux
etats-unis également où on en régissent
2000 nouveaux décès aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le nombre de morts en milieu hospitalier
en france grimpe donc à 7600 32 soit 7
141 500 parts dont 41 décès
supplémentaires lors des dernières 24
heures annonce il y à quelques instants
de jérôme salomon directeur général de
la santé en raison d'un problème
technique informatique qui empêchent
l'accès à l'application santé publique
france on ne pouvait pas dans le dos
mais ce soir le bilan des ehpad le bilan
ne concerne donc que le milieu
hospitalier si on prend le chiffre de
mortalité dans les ehpad hier cela fait
dix mille 328 morts dans l'hexagone tout
chiffre confondues 2053 et le bilan des
décès reprend donc ce soir
la mortalité hospitalière 7630 deux
décès sont à déplorer depuis le 1er mars
82 % des décès observés surviennent chez
des personnes de plus de 70 ans
au cours des dernières 24 heures c'est
donc un total de 5 141 décès étaient
enregistrés en milieu hospitalier
enfin et c'est important 21250 quatre
personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital ce chiffre continue
d'augmenter jour après jour et bien
entendu il faut y ajouter les dizaines
de milliers de personnes guéries à la
maison et qui n'ont pas eu besoin fort
heureusement d'être hospitalisée et la
situation dramatique au sein des ehpad
on en parle avec un jean paul hamon
médecin généraliste président de la
fédération des médecins de france
bonsoir docteur amant merci d'être avec
nous alors une fois n'est pas coutume un
depuis une semaine vous le savez on
comptabilise le nombre de victimes dans
les ehpad c'est pas le cas ce soir en
raison d'un problème technique mais les
chiffres sont de mauvais augure
hier on nous les donner est ce que cette
situation dont les épate vous inquiètent
particulièrement la situation dans les
ehpad nous inquiète
depuis depuis le début on avait dit nous
on a supprimé les visites à domicile des
médecins
on fonctionne avec avec le médecin
coordinateur de l'ehpad et ont fait plus
de monde c'est plus de co2 de devises à
domicile on avait critiqué le fait que
les familles
ne puisse pas venir mais on s'aperçoit
que c'est pas suffisant que les
soignants eux sortent rencontre du monde
et est l'absence de test fait qu' il y
en a certainement qui ont contaminé des
personnes fragiles et donc ce qui devait
arriver est en train d'arriver
les les personnes âgées fragiles parce
que je rappelle quand même que quand on
voit dans une ehpad
c'est pour les trois dernières années de
la vie donc on est on est on a vraiment
des poils et de des polypathologies on
est on est fragile et donc ces personnes
là par contre premier c'est ce qu'il
fallait craindre
justement vous parliez des tests docteur
olivier verront annoncé hier une
opération massive de dépistage en des
personnels et des résidents dans les
ehpad
ça arrive trop tard tout arrive trop
tard les masques sont arrivés trop tard
le le fait que le fait qu'on ne dépiste
pas les gens qu'on n'ait pas de masque
pour mettre à la population l'exemple de
la corée du sud je le cite souvent mais
ils ont réussi à enrayer une épidémie
qui partait vraiment très très fort
parce que la population est masqué par
ce qu'ils ont fait des tests massif
parce qu'ils ont suivi les personnes qui
étaient contaminés qu'ils ont fait ici
allez allez contrôler donc
malheureusement on prend la leçon de 2,7
de cette pandémie mais mais s'il est
clair que on peut pas se permettre de ne
pas avoir de stock ou protéger la
population et pour protéger le personnel
soignant un docteur ramon clairement
voulu tout est arrivé trop tard on sait
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement avait
été prévenu il ya eu plusieurs rapports
y compris même par jérôme c'est le mans
qui avait bien en allemand prévenu de
cette possible épidémie
bill gates des rapports de l'essayer à
bref on ne les compte plus pourquoi le
gouvernement n'a pas réagi
selon vous visiblement ce gouvernement d
épaule seule en europe à avoir réagi un
lait on voit bien que les populations
banque de masques que les soignants
banque de masquer les seuls qui ont
l'air de sortir leur épingle du jeu ce
sont les allemands qui ont quatre fois
plus de lits de réanimation que les
français et qui prennent des des
patients français en réanimation
il y aura une morale il y aura une des
consignes et des conclusions à tirer de
cette de ces tristes épisodes et de
cette impréparation et et j'espère
qu'elles seront vraiment tirer pour
revenir juste quelques instants sur la
situation dans les ehpad vous avez fait
allusion la critique un concernant la
solitude ces personnes-là l'impuissance
des familles notamment pour leur venir
en aide
est ce que réellement on prend le
problème dans le bon sens vous venez de
le dire vous même ce sont les trois
dernières années de vie est ce qu'on n'a
pas plutôt intérêt justement à rendre la
vie peut-être plus agréable au risque
voilà deux peut-être une mise entre
légèrement supérieur on peut mourir de
solitude aussi oui mais rendre la vie
plus agréable en ce moment c'est c est
leur éviter d'attraper d'attraper le
qu'ovide 19 parce que il est clair que
dans les ehpad quand quelqu'un de très
âgés de polypathologiques fait at
rappelé que 8,19 on est on est tout de
suite dans les soins dans les soins
palliatifs on n'est plus dans le curatif
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on peut
pas intubé et leur mettre une assistance
respiratoire
les personnes âgées polypathologiques
fragiles ne le supporte pas donc on est
immédiatement dans le palliatif donc
c'est vrai que si c'est pour quelques
semaines de confinement
on peut se débrouiller après il ya
toujours ya toujours des tablettes dans
l'est dans les ehpad
on peut on peut communiquer avec avec
skype même si c'est par la personne âgée
qui va faire la manipulation mais on
peut communiquer avec les tablettes avec
facetime et c'est donc tout ça c'est
possible de le faire de façon totalement
sécurisée et sans que les personnes se
sentent isolés vous savez la plupart
celles qui ont celle qui ont leur
conscience et celles qui ont en leur
jugement sont tout à fait capables de
comprendre pourquoi leur famille ne
vient pas les voir vous parliez
justement si ça ne devait durer qu'un
temps l'occurrence là on nous dit tous
les jours en edouard philippe
sans nous le rappeler le confinement va
durer d'ailleurs se refuse à évoquer une
stratégie de déconfinement quelle est la
réaction du médecin vous êtes ah ben on
sait très bien que quand ils ont dix
quinze jours de de confinement et qu'on
a vu là la horde lors de des français
qui quitté paris pour aller se réfugier
en province ils avaient tous compris que
ça n'allait pas durer 15 jours tout ce
qui pourrait partir et qu'il y avait du
télétravail sont partis avec armes et
bagages et enfants et ils savaient très
bien que ça allait durer ça allait durer
plus de quinze jours et là en ce moment
parler de déconfinement est totalement
prématuré 534 morts par jour 800 hier on
voit bien que ça
ça ne baisse pas et je pense qu'on fera
sans doute le bilan à la mi mai mais à
la mi mai on sera certainement pas tirés
d'affaires il suffit de regarder des
italiens qui en quinze jours d'avancé
sur nous ils sont loin d'être tiré
d'affaires et on parle pas des
confinement on voit quelques opérations
de communication en chine disant qu' il
des consignes des quelques quartiers de
pékin mais qu'ils envoient sur la grande
muraille mais si vous avez vu les images
fournies par les chinois sur la grande
muraille à un chinois tous les 50 mètres
donc donc c'est de l'opération
communication plus long jean paul hamon
vous dites oui quand on voit cette horde
et des français voilà je me fais
volontairement provocatrice mais enfin
il n'y a pas un petit peu de
culpabilisation de deux de ces français
tout serait de la faute de ceux qui
veulent quitter paris il n'empêche c'est
quand même compliqué ce confinement dans
une ville comme paris dans des
appartements où on est avec des enfants
est-ce que ce n'était pas peut-être au
gouvernement d'anticiper un petit peu
plus peut-être cette situation de nous
fournir des tests des masques vous
l'avez dit vous-même la corée s'en sort
mieux les allemands aussi
le gouvernement vous savez il a fait il
a fait ce qu'ils pouvaient un bon ils
ont constaté
ils ont constaté qu' il pouvait pas
avoir de masques que deux le stock de
masques avait disparu où on n'avait pas
été renouvelé il avait quand même deux
mois pour leur faire et relancer la
machine à fabrication française puisque
en chine visiblement on se piquer les
les contenus des avions sur le tarmac
parce qu'ils sont plus offrant donc tout
ça
on est on est à la merci le on est à la
merci le président a rappelé enfin qu'il
fallait qu'on ait une indépendance de
production pour les matériels de
protection
il n'a pas parlé de l'indépendance de
production de test et pourtant c'est ce
qu'il faudrait avoir maintenant pour le
pour le déconfinement c'est vrai que les
parisiens qui ont eu la chance d'avoir
des parents qui pourraient travailler en
télétravail et quelques une maison à la
campagne au bord de la mer bon bah
c'était plutôt une bonne chose de partir
même si même si en faisant ça ils
prenaient le risque de faire flamber
l'épidémie il semble quand même que
c'est pas été le cas
et que une fois sur place ils ont été
raisonnables ou les a contraints à les
13 hommes
donc il faut rester il faut rester
confiné maintenant il ya ya que cette il
ya que cette façon de contenir
l'épidémie de faire en sorte que comme
dans tous les autres pays il faut éviter
que les services de réanimation soient
débordés parce que qu'on ne se retrouve
pas dans la situation italienne où ils
ont été obligés de choisir entre ce
qu'ils allaient réanimer ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas réanimer
pour le moment en france ça tient mais
ça tient à un fil et je pense qu'il est
prématuré de parler des continents
justement la situation est la solution
ne semble venir vous venez de le dire
d'ailleurs que du confinement strict des
français quid d'un éventuel traitement
est ce que vous vous savez de l'espoir
ont ces différents traitements mon
sommes en train de tester un peu partout
en france
il ya des études qui sont en cours il ya
des études qui sont en cours il ya cette
fameuse chloroquine associé à
l'azithromycine qui j'espère que l'étude
qui est en cours avec l'université
d'angers
bah pas montré l'utilité de ce
médicament tout le monde le souhaite
mais pour le moment on aurait aucune
preuve donc ce serait ce serait bien que
une étude indépendante une réalité
scientifique nous nous fasse la preuve
que ce médicament est utile et on attend
ça avec impatience
nous aussi effectivement merci et
jean-paul à mon médecin généraliste
président de la fédération des médecins
de france merci beaucoup d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france et
aujourd'hui encore à interroger cette
fois par les sénateurs sur le
confinement le premier ministre edouard
philippe rapp palais a rappelé qu'il
était appelée à durer
on peut faire un point d'étape mais on
ne peut pas faire le bilan définitif du
confinement car le confinement est
appelée à durer si il ne durait pas ou
s'ils n'étaient pas respectées nous
prendrions le risque qui en vérité ne
serait pas un risque qui serait une
certitude
de voir le virus circule est à nouveau
très vite et donc le nombre de cas a
admis en réanimation augmenté alors même
que le tissu hospitalier a été sur
sollicité et qui se trouve dans un état
de stress de fatigue qu'il faut
évidemment bien avoir en tête c'est la
raison pour laquelle je dis
régulièrement que leur dû des
confinement n'est pas venue toute notre
énergie doit être consacré à faire en
sorte que le confinement soit respecté
pour que les effets positifs de ce
confinement puisse se confirmer dans le
nombre de cas sévères admis en
réanimation
on appris aujourd'hui le limogeage du
directeur de l'agencé régionale de santé
du grand test cette nouvelle intervient
quelques jours après une prise de parole
qui n'est pas passée et christophe
lannelongue a affirmé qu'il n'y avait
pas de raison de remettre en cause la
suppression de 174 l'ieee près de 600
postes sur cinq ans au chu de nancy et
les français font-ils confiance au
gouvernement pour gérer cette crise
selon un sondage et lab pour bfm tv
c'est non pour 56% d'entre eux en cause
notamment les nombreux couacs de
l'exécutif concernant les municipales la
pénurie de masse ou de gel
hydroalcoolique je vous propose
d'écouter certains d'entre mécontents
franchement ils ont cette gestion
catastrophique vraiment l'être
calamiteuse et je pense qu'il faudra
vraiment pour qu'ils rendent des comptes
cela s'est pas c'est pas le moment mais
je pense qu'il y aura un moment il
faudra vraiment qu'ils qu'ils rendent
des comptes
et si pouvant table c'est épouvantable
ils ont un moyen de communication
complètement débile dire aux gens que le
masque ne sert à rien parce qu'on en a
pas c'est prendre les gens pour des
irresponsables au lieu d'être franc et
de leur dire on n'a pas de masque
protégez vous comme vous pouvez c'est
complètement assassins de leur dire
qu'elle va ce qu'on ne sert à rien c'est
pas le moment de critiquer je crois et
puis c'est difficile à dire comment on
ferait nous à leur place
1 peut-être qu'il ya eu un retard ou
démarrage mais bon après presse et du
fils il est difficile à dire c'est un
peu compliqué hein tu peu compliqué si
on a l'impression qu'on nous dit pas
tout un coup faut pas avoir de masse
parce que c'est uniquement les gens qui
sont contagieux aujourd'hui enfin et
demain on va nous dire tous porter des
masques
moi j'ai eu la chance de récupérer 1 et
encore je les utilise à chaque fois que
je sors donc je pense pas qu'il soit
efficace mais voilà on aurait pu dire
aux gens au moins on n'a pas de masque
mais fait quelque chose protégez vous je
pense et pour parler de la communication
du gouvernement mais aussi d'allocutions
d' emmanuel macron prévue demain nous
sommes avec alexis poulain cofondateur
de la revue le monde moderne
bonsoir alexis est cool un merci d'être
avec nous en direct à temps sur rt
france avoir 56 % des français ne font
pas confiance au gouvernement selon ce
sondage là on a entendu des français pas
contents mais vous verrez si je me
trompe alexis poulain on a le sentiment
que les français ne se rebelle pas
tellement les français pourtant habitué
à être plus tôt rana
les entend pas beaucoup il semble plutôt
accepter les règles de ce confinement
strict sens d'ailleurs espoir de sortie
pour l'instant 1
mais évidemment je crois que les
français sont responsables dans leur
grande majorité ils savent très bien ce
qu'ils ont à faire
limiter la propagation de ce virus pour
aider les soignants à ne pas avoir un
affût une vague supplémentaires dans
l'est dans les oeufs dans les hôpitaux
le problème c'est tout c'est toutes ces
injonctions contradictoires café
l'exécutif depuis ces dernières semaines
d'une semaine à l'autre il fallait aller
au théâtre pour soutenir l'activité des
spectacles et puis aller voter et puis
rester chez soi et ne surtout plus
sortir et puis une fois qu'on est chez
soi on avait le droit de faire du
jogging on n'a plus le droit de faire du
jogging entre 10h à 19h enfin on a
l'impression qu'on joue avec les
français en fait en leur demandant
jacques a dit restez chez vous jacadi
vous pouvez sortir entre 10 et 12 heures
jacadi fait ça à jacques a pas dis donc
ça fallait pas le faire
les français sont pas idiots ils voient
bien que par contre on les a pris pour
des idiots
c'est le cas de votre micro trottoir on
voit tous ces gens qui ont dit mais il
suffisait de nous dire la vérité on n'a
pas besoin de mensonges ci avait pas de
masque fallait le dire mais il fallait
dire aux gens faites des masques
débrouillez vous pour vous protéger
d'une autre façon au delà des gestes
barrières
sauf que le choix de l'exécutif et du
gouvernement ça a été de mentir pour
couvrir la pénurie la pénurie de moyens
de masquer la pénurie à l'hôpital bien
entendu la pénurie de test et maintenant
on se retrouve et que c'est une
situation du confinement que les
français respectent tout en étant quand
même très circonspect avec le risque que
cette sortie de confinement soit à
retarder et que la sortie soit terrible
pour notamment l'activité économique
alors vous ne croyez pas si bien dire
alexis poulain puisque dans le au même
moment en direct l'elysée
annoncerait l'instant que le
prolongement du confinement irait au
delà du 15 avril à emmanuel macron qui
devrait s'exprimer demain mais aussi
lundi sans toujours tout en évitant la
question du déconfinement ça comment
peuvent le vivre les français sachant
que nos voisins européens eux commencent
à élaborer quand même des des stratégies
de déconfinement et c'est une politique
totalement improvisée c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de stratégie on voit on voit en
fait inanité l'impéritie de ce
gouvernement dans cette crise on a
affaire à des néo manager des gens qui
sont des rh qui viennent du privé qui
n'ont pas le sens de l'état ni la
stature d'homme d'état pour gérer une
crise majeure
et qu'est ce qu'ils font et bien il gère
le court terme
donc on va faire quinze jours puis on va
refaire quinze jours c'était le choix de
faire comme en angleterre
eh bien on va attendre de voir comment
ça se passe et puis les chiffres étant
tel qu'il va falloir ensuite adapté plus
tôt aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on demande
qu'est ce que demandent les français de
la planification de l'ordre et de la
clarté et surtout surtout de la
sincérité
oui le déconfinement on peut y penser
dès maintenant ces mêmes urgent d'y
penser dès maintenant pour ne pas avoir
le retard qu'on a eu ce soir tout sur le
territoire rappelez vous c'était dans
l'oise s'étaient dans le grand test avec
quelques cluster vous avez on appelait
ça cluster à l'époque mais au lieu de
prendre les mesures qui auraient été à
l'époque qui aurait pu sans doute éviter
la propagation du virus
on a attendu on a improvisé et
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait on
voudrait improvisé et ne pas planifier
la sortie du bourg ont finement mais
comment vous dites ça à des patrons de
pme comme on dit ça à des gens qui ont
besoin de travailler parce que sans ça
n'y a pas d'argent alors ok si vous
confiner les gens monsieur emmanuel
macron alors à ce moment là
ces moratoires sur les loyers que les
gens qui sont locataires n'est plus à
payer les loyers le temps du confinement
ces moratoires sur un paquet de trucs
sur les factures de gaz d'électricité
d'eau etc
si les gens ne peuvent pas travailler
alors ils ne doivent pas payer c'est
aussi simple que ça et si vous voulez
relancer l'économie il va falloir penser
déconfinement parce que ce qui va se
passer c'est des faillites massives de
pme alors oui effectivement les grandes
entreprises du cac 40
s'en fichent puisqu'ils ont des usines
qui tournent à peu près sur tous les
continents donc ils peuvent toujours se
rattraper
quand un pays va reprendre ça ira mais
pour les entreprises françaises qui sont
sur ce territoire qui n'ont que ça vous
êtes en train de mettre à la rue des
millions de français et dire que l'état
payera c'est simplement annoncé une
faillite générale c'est à dire que si on
ne relance pas l'économie si on ne fait
pas en sorte que l'on puisse simplement
organiser le retour à une vie normale
et pour ça il faut des masques il faut
des tests il faut des traitements
pourquoi pas revenir encore sur la
chloroquine on apprend qu'il va falloir
attendre fin avril pour avoir un
résultat sur l' enquête discovery on
aurait pu accélérer tout ça c'est à dire
que tout ce qui nous manque aujourd'hui
fait que la sortie du confinement va
être encore plus difficile pour tout le
monde on perd 6 points de pib
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ce sera si on
a encore un mois de confinement mais je
n'ose même pas y penser
avec en plus des partenaires européens
qui ne jouent pas le jeu on est en plein
sommet européen on voit bien rien ne se
passe aujourd'hui sur la solidarité
européenne donc faut pas croire
là-dessus faut pas s'attendre à quoi que
ce soit donc aujourd'hui oui on doit
parler déconfinement on doit surtout le
planifier et on doit surtout ne pas
faire l'erreur qui a été faite au début
de cette crise c'est à dire de naviguer
à vue
d'improviser le fait justement qu
emmanuel macron ne donne aucune date va
être prolongée elle a gelé devant le nez
cette dépêche au delà du 15 avril
il s'exprimera lundi manuel macron après
20 heures pour présenter ses décisions
concernant cette lutte contre le
coronavirus qu'est ce que ça dit
effectivement comment vous la jugez
cette communication d'emmanuel macron
qui dans le même temps se rend en seine
saint denis sans masque avec des gens
agglutinés autour de lui c'est toute la
communication de mellac rond depuis le
début c'est à dire une mise en scène
tragique
rien ne se passe comme ça devrait il est
dehors dans la rue sans masquer ses
gardes du corps sont sans masque et
arrivent les badauds qui s'agglutinent
autour de lui et il dit respecter les
mesures barrières il se met en scène
avec des gens au balcon en joignant les
mains on parle de deux présidentes les
rois capétiens et autres
c'est du délire c'est à dire que on est
dans une communication spectacle mais
certainement pas dans une communication
de crise qui serait à la hauteur de
cette crise
aujourd'hui on a simplement quelqu'un
qui est en train d'essayer de masquer
les manquements de son gouvernement sous
couvert d'une guerre contre un ennemi
invisible une guerre qu'on n'est pas en
train de gagner parce que si on lit
l'art de la guerre de sun tzu et bien
emmanuel macron a tout faux et il ne
réussit pas en fait à mobiliser les
troupes il ne réussit pas à prévenir ce
qui sera l'étape d'après on est dans la
gestion de la 2de en fait à retardement
plutôt que de prévoir c'est le cas
pourquoi pourquoi on ne veut pas parler
de déconfinement aujourd'hui parce qu'il
ya pas de plan tout simplement
donc on a pourquoi à quoi servent les
conseils de guerre à quoi servent tous
ces experts aussi docte s'ils sont
incapables de nous aider d'aider le pays
en fait à en sortir
cette communication hier qu'est ce
qu'elle montre elle montre bien
exactement ce que fait mal mâcon depuis
le début le en même temps je vous dis de
rester chez vous mais moi je sors je
vous dis protégez vous mais je ne me
protège pas je vais voir des soignants
leur demandant ce qu'ils leur manquent
ils disent à peu près tout mais je leur
apporte pas de masque ils arriveront dû
attendre jusqu'à fin juin pour avoir
tous les masques commandés en chine
donc c'est une mise en scène de
l'impossibilité de gouverner c'est une
mise en scène du nom pouvoir c'est une
mise en scène de la capacité
c'est triste c'est inquiétant c'est
encore plus inquiétant quand on ne donne
pas de date quant on ne donne pas de cap
quand finalement on ne gouverne pas ce
qui se montre aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
un président qui a été élu et qui est
incapable de gouverner
autre critique elle porte sur ce premier
tour des élections municipales qui s'est
tenue le 15 mars on a entendu beaucoup
de deux maires de communes dont tant
qu'ils avaient gagné au premier tour à
100% qu'ils demandent carrément
l'annulation de ce scrutin est ce que ça
peut être considéré selon vous comme une
faute politique du gouvernement macron
mais si c'était la seule mais évidemment
c'est une faute tragique
je suis allé voter beaucoup de français
sont allés voter on parce que on croit
cette parole politique on croit à un
moment oui on nous dit qu'on peut aller
voter alors on va voter
on a pris toutes les précautions
nécessaires mais quand on voit le nombre
d'assesseurs le nombre de mères la façon
dont les bureaux certains bureaux n'ont
pas respecté
les mesures de protection on est devant
un scandale sanitaire majeur on est
devant une faute grave c'est à dire que
demandait aux français d'aller voter
sachant que deux jours après parce que
ne me faites pas croire que on allait
prévoir comme ça du jour au lendemain
que le confinement arriverait deux jours
après le premier tour
sachant qu'il n'y aurait pas de deuxième
tour mais enfin c'est quoi cette
politique c'est ce que je vous dis sur
cette incapacité de gouverner gouverner
c'est prévoir emmanuel macron ne prévoit
rien il est fait pour simplement gérer
c'est un gestionnaire néo manager il est
là pour gérer en temps de nos crises
quand tout va bien pour faire du profit
à court terme il est banquier d'affaires
voilà ce qu'il fait quand on est un
homme d'état on doit prévoir et
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui sont
simplement des poulets sans tête qui
court sans savoir vraiment quoi faire et
qui ont comme priorité principale de
sauver les arrières et de dire c'est pas
ma faute j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait
c'est pas moi le responsable cette crise
était telle que je pouvais pas la
prévoir voilà le petit discours qui est
en train d'être sorti mais ils sont
responsables
choisir la politique c'est choisir la
responsabilité vouloir s'en défausser
c'est scandaleux et on va voir des
commission parlementaire présidée par
richard ferrand les amis etc qui vont
les dédouaner bien entendu mais les
français ne sont pas dupes encore une
fois ils ont bien vu ce qu'il s'est
passé
des gens qui ont menti des gens qui ont
fait semblant des gens qui ont couvert
la pénurie le manque et qui les ont mis
en danger eux-mêmes eux et leur famille
et aujourd'hui c'est une crise beaucoup
plus large bien sûr on va pas accusé
uniquement le gouvernement mais on est
aujourd'hui dans un blocage qui
s'appelle le confinement mais c'est
simplement un blocage parce que on a été
incapable certains qui aurait pu prévoir
parce qu'ils sont élus pour prévoir
n'ont pas fait leur boulot tout
simplement merci beaucoup alexis et
approuvé un cofondateur de la revue le
monde moderne d'avoir été avec nous
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du projet d'application
mobile du gouvernement pour identifier
les chaînes de transmission du virus
nous resterons en france la france qui
est entrée officiellement en récession
avec le pib qui plonge de 6 % au premier
trimestre l'europe groupe lui tente de
trouver
une réponse économique comme une
nouvelle réunion demain après un échec
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france
avez vous été en contact ces derniers
jours avec des personnes atteintes du
comique 19 vous pourriez bientôt le
savoir par le biais d'autres téléphones
mobiles
la france travaille actuellement sur un
projet d'application pour identifier les
chaînes de transmission du virus le
projet suscite quelques craintes chez
les défenseurs des libertés
individuelles mais le gouvernement se
veut lui rassurant de les explications
[Musique]
oh
le
[Musique]
et
beaucoup de monde
[Musique]
et pour parler de cette application de
traçage des malades à l'étude par le
gouvernement nous sommes en direct avec
cédric dubuc avocat spécialiste des
nouvelles technologies bonsoir cédric
dubuc merci d'être avec nous quel est le
regard du juriste sur cette proposition
écoutez c'est un jeu excessivement
fondamental dans la mesure où finalement
il est question de mettre le curseur au
bon endroit entre la sécurité la liberté
ce n'était pas une question uniquement
technique ce n'est pas uniquement une
question technologique la france
finalement est confronté à la question
de savoir comment se passera le
déconfinement et évidemment elle a
plusieurs hypothèses et fit évidemment
il y allait militer collective il ya le
vaccin l'immunité kg collected à mon
avis est une hypothèse pour l'instant
assez improbable le vaccin niveau que 12
à 18 mois
il ya le médicament en nous évoque la
date de juillet mais on n'est pas sûr
et ensuite il ya effectivement des
méthodes qui ont déjà fait leurs preuves
on pourrait du sud en chine à singapour
qui sont quand même des régimes semi
autoritaire et la méthode effectivement
pour efficaces qu'elles soient retranche
finalement un certain nombre de libertés
individuelles comme la liberté
évidemment lié à la vie privée puisque
finalement l'état s'immiscerait dans le
téléphone portable où il y a finalement
toute notre vie pour nous tracer entre
guillemets en tout cas s'assurer des
interactions sociales que l'on pourrait
avoir dans la journée pour retracer la
chaîne de virus dans l'hypothèse où il y
aurait un cas positif
donc c'est un effectivement c'est une
technologie qui est en train d'être mise
sur pied par le gouvernement
on nous assure qu'il ya des garde-fous
j'avais à dire heureusement et je pense
qu'il faut être excessivement vigilant
lorsqu'on doit s'assurer finalement
d'apporter limites voire des
renonciations à un certain nombre de nos
libertés
alors pour le moment ça serait sur la
base du volontariat ça ne vous rassure
pas ça justement si vous voulez j'avais
heureusement que c'est sur la base du
volontariat
c'est pas le cas dans tous les pays
c'est vrai mais si vous voulez on prend
la chimie comme exemple la chine est un
bel exemple en termes de sécurité je ne
pense pas que la chine soit un exemple à
suivre en termes de libertés
individuelles mais une chute qui a kiss
est sorti beaucoup mieux que nous de
cette crise il faut bien le dire avec
évidemment pas que cette méthode de
tracking mais quand même ça a beaucoup
contribué
c'est une méthode excessivement efficace
vous avez raison de le dire il faut
s'assurer en france finalement d'avoir
des garde-fous finalement par rapport à
ces tests et à ces technologies par la
lave enfin le fait que ça sur un
phénomène de volontaires c'est la
moindre des choses
il ya d'autres examens de foi en la vie
qui doivent être utilisés par exemple
évidemment s'assurer que les données à
mon avis soit décentralisée on l'a
évoqué la technologie bluetooth il a
peut-être la technologie bluemotion qui
peut être adapté le fait que les données
soit anonymisée me paraît effectivement
être une absolue nécessité
le fait aussi de s'assurer que
l'utilisation de ces données soient
strictement limitées vous faites de
remonter la chaîne de kobe de 19
il ne faudrait pas effectivement que ces
données sortent du cadre strictement
sanitaires et finalement que les
autorités administratives voire
judiciaire s'empare de ces données-là la
cnil évidemment doit nécessairement
valider cette application et je ferai
observé qu'elle a déjà rendu une
décision notamment qui limite par
exemple les relevés obligatoire des
température corporelle de chaque salarié
à gembloux visiteurs donc vous avez
raison c'est efficace il faut bien
excessivement attention lorsqu'on soit
être finalement enlever un peu de
liberté pour un coût de sécurité à
l'ancien président des états unis
expliqué qu'on allait perdre finalement
les deux et qu'on était digne ni l'un ni
l'autre
il faut faire attention voilà c'est
simplement ce que je ce que je dis est
ce que ça serait la fin du sacro saint
secret médical selon vous l'enjeu
je ne pense pas parce que finalement le
secret médical est opposable aux
médecins là en l'occurrence
effectivement ce serait des données liés
aux interactions sociales les individus
dans dans les roues l'idée finalement ce
serait de faire remonter la chaîne du
coc vide 19
donc ce serait finalement les autorités
sanitaires qui pourrait s'emparer d'une
information ou a priori nolly mire la
liberté serait potentiellement
sauvegarde et si on en croit le
gouvernement qui se veut rassurant
j'emploie des guillemets mais il faut
s'assurer effectivement que ces
limitations sont strictement
proportionnée à la liberté individuelle
alors selon un sondage a mené par
l'université d'oxford
huit français sur dix se serait déclaré
être prêts à télécharger à utiliser une
telle application est ce que ça ça vous
étonne vous en tant qu'avocat ça veut
dire que peut-être le la privation de
liberté tout simplement d'aller et venir
est encore plus mal vécue que celle de
révéler un petit peu de sa vie privée
oui alors tu poses et qu'il fallait
choisir entre les deux et que ce ne soit
pas cumulatif mélo vous avez raison
c'est que si on en croit les sondages
les gens sont potentiellement près en
tout cas collectivement à télécharger
cette application c'est c'est peut-être
une bonne nouvelle d'un point de vue de
la sécurité
il faut à nouveau s'assurer des
conditions de la détention de ces
informations par le gouvernement je peux
prendre quelques exemples évidemment
mais il faut éviter les dérives je pense
que c'est là où il faut être
excessivement rigide
par exemple vous savez avec le même type
d'arguments on pourra aller jusqu'à deux
mètres la reconnaissance faciale
on pourrait mettre finalement que la
sécurité justifierait de tri entre les
bons et les mauvais citoyens
on pourrait aussi imaginer que ces
données puissent être extraites et
finalement on pourrait prolonger
finalement autorisation les
el2 d'extraire ces données on pourrait
peut-être les transmettre à l'autorité
judiciaire
on pourrait peut-être pourquoi pas aller
jusqu'à exter septembre deux des nôtres
téléphone pour vous assurer que vous
respecter la liberté d'expression
enfin je comment dire je souhaite
simplement m'assurer que nous sommes en
guerre effectivement que cette liberté
qui est la liberté pour télé sa vie
privée doit être sans doute restreinte
en ce moment le 8 français sur 10 y sont
adorables il faut s'assurer
effectivement que ce soit excessivement
bien cantonné est-ce que alors c'est
peut-être pas le propos d'un à joris qui
reste évidemment factuel il ya un danger
peut-être que certains gouvernements pas
forcément du gouvernement français se
servent de cette crise sanitaire et du
danger tout simplement sur la vie des
personnes pour outrepasser certains
droits et viol et peut-être certaines
libertés publiques c'est l'avis de
l'avocat que vous êtes aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas d'avis et finalement changé
d'avis en tout cas sur la question de
savoir si oui ou non le gouvernement
français envisage de limiter autant que
ses modèles chinois coréen na pour rien
nos limites et nos libertés
individuelles
je ne sais pas quelle idée ils ont dans
la tête je sais qu'il envisage le
tracking comme une méthode effectivement
permettant d'être assez efficace huit
français sur dix sont positifs tant
mieux positif à cette idée naturellement
moi je ne dis rien de plus finalement
que il faut s'assurer que cette
limitation soit limité dans le temps
strictement proportionnées et s'assimile
effectivement avec ce que nous sommes et
avec notre conception de la liberté
merci beaucoup cédric dubuc avocat
spécialiste des nouvelles technologies
et on en vient à présent aux
conséquences économiques de la pandémie
c'est officiel nous sommes entrés en
récession le pib chute de près de 6% au
premier trimestre sans précédent depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale
un français sur quatre est au chômage
partiel et le ministre de l'économie
le maire s'est exprimé aujourd'hui il se
veut rassurant sur les risques de
pénurie alimentaire en france il n'y en
aura pas selon lui il n'y a pas une
pénurie alimentaire en france et il n'y
aura pas de pénurie alimentaire en
france c'est l'engagement que nous
avions pris avec le ministre
d'agriculture
l'engagement a été tenu grâce à la
mobilisation exceptionnelle de toute la
chaîne alimentaire et je pense que c'est
un motif de fierté pour nous tous de se
dire qu'en france la sécurité
alimentaire même en période de crise est
garanti et les garanties parce que nous
avons une production agricole
indépendante forte parce que les
agriculteurs continuent à produire parce
que les produits sont transformés qui
sont transportés que la grande
distribution ont parfaitement joué le
jeu notamment de l'achat de produits
agricoles français que le commerce de
détail que les marchés en plein vent
enfin tous les acteurs de la chaîne ont
parfaitement joué le jeu je voudrais
vraiment m'associer à l'hommage qui a
été rendu par le ministre de la culture
à tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui au
travail pour garantir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement des français cette
alerte de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce selon l'om c'est le commerce
mondial pourrait chuter de près d'un
tiers en 2020
une situation pire que celle de 2008 il
faut s'attendre à la pire récession
économique de notre existence selon son
directeur général
alors que nous sommes confrontés à ce
qui pourrait bien être la plus profonde
récession ou le plus grand
ralentissement économique de notre
existence nous devrions chercher à tirer
le meilleur parti de tous les moteurs
potentiels de la croissance durable pour
inverser cette situation
les gouvernements du monde entier
peuvent et doivent jeter les bases d'une
reprise forte et socialement inclusive
le commerce et plus généralement la
coordination internationale seront des
ingrédients importants à cet égard new
year les ministres des finances de
l'union européenne n'ont pas trouvé
d'accord sur la riposte commune à tenir
face à cette pandémie
le ministre allemand des finances
exhorte à un effort collectif a thing
je pense qu'il est absolument clair que
le rétablissement de l'europe sera une
très grande tâche que nous devons
organiser ensemble et comme tout le
monde le sait je pense qu'il sera
possible de le faire dans le cadre que
nous avons déjà ça autorise selon moi il
est donc très judicieux de discuter de
ce qui pourrait être fait dans le cadre
du prochain cfp et dans le cadre
financier pour les prochaines années que
nous devons déjà décidé having to decide
aurait des les précisions de notre
reporter monnaie un modèle à part émis
en tir de discussion 16h aux
négociations exactement aucun accord n a
été trouvée car les pays du nord et ceux
du sud n'ont pas trouvé un terrain
d'entente et des solutions connues et
satisfaisante
marseille le président de l'aca secteur
après 16 heures de discussions nous nous
sommes rapprochés d'un accord mais nous
n'y sommes pas encore j'ai suspendu leur
groupe qui continuera demain jeudi
mon objectif reste le même un filet de
sécurité européen solide contre les
retombées du coc vie 19 et s'engager
dans un plan de relance importants
savoir que le point initial comprenait
le prêt d'un fonds de secours d'un
montant de 240 milliards d'euros il
était considéré comme un fonds de
garantie pour les entreprises et un
soutien au chômage partiel mais les pays
les plus touchés par les balles à part
la pandémie comme l'italie est la france
l'espagne ou encore à la grèce réclame
un effort financier plus important
il demande concrètement la création d'un
instrument de dette comment appeler les
corps en a bomb destiné à relancer
l'économie sur le long terme
une fois la crise passée et c'est là où
il y a un problème puisque ces
propositions ont été catégoriquement
refusées par les pays de l'europe du
nord comme la finlande et pays-bas
l'autriche ou encore la suède qui ne
veulent pas payer les pots cassés ils
s'opposent à l'idée d'une mutualisation
des dettes puisque certains pays du sud
de l'europe sont trop endettés une
rencontre en visioconférence qui a
laissé place donc à deux quand celui des
pays du sud de l'europe
très touché par la crise et y ont besoin
d'argent est ce celui des pays du nord
de l'europe qui font front commun et ces
négociations elles ont révélé finalement
les lignes de fracture de l'union
européenne alors que l'union doit
trouver rapidement des solutions
ses citoyens les discussions doivent
néanmoins apprendre reprendront demain
jeudi 9 avril et si un accord était
trouvé il devrait encore être approuvé
par les chefs d'état pour l'instant ça
s'annonce assez compliqué et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec jean
marc sylvestre journaliste éditorialiste
économique bonsoir jean marc sylvestre
merci d'être avec nous la pire
performance trimestrielle de l'économie
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale rien que ça qu'elle est
jean marc sylvestre votre réaction
écoutez ma réaction si je suis
effectivement atterré par l'ampleur des
dégâts que provoque cette crise et dans
le monde entier
alors que la france en a des chiffres
qui ont été avancés par la bande que de
france aujourd'hui à titre provisoire
mais ils correspondent à la réalité
c'est que nous avons perdu en gros 6% de
pipe par rapport à l'année dernière sur
la même période pour le premier
trimestre et que nous perdons en gros à
peu près à ennemis % à chaque quinze
jours de confinement ça veut dire que si
on est encore confiné pendant tout le
mois d'avril et bien on va on va
avoisiner presque les 10% de récession
record en termes annuels à partir du
mois prochain
donc c'est absolument colossal alors ça
a deux particularités qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que la première sexy
mondial c'est que pour la première fois
toute l'économie mondiale s'est arrêté
au même moment pratiquement parce que
tous les moteurs de l'économie sont
arrêtés vous n'avez pas de consommation
les moteurs de l'économie c'est quoi
c'est la consommation c'est
l'investissement et c'est l'exportation
la consommation ces parts étaient
évidemment parce que les gens ne
consomment plus ils restent confinés
chez eux et puis ils vont au minimum
c'est-à-dire l'agroalimentaire et puis
les questions de sécurité les
investissements ont tous été arrêtés et
ont tous été reportée regarder ce qui se
passe dans l'aéronautique on ne l'achète
plus l'avion n'achète plus de l'aude
dans l'automobile dans la construction
bon et puis le commerce extérieur il est
également planté dans les ports dans les
oreilles a plus un seul avion dans l'air
donc c'est une véritable catastrophe
dans la mesure où le monde entier rité
mais la deuxième conséquence la deuxième
chose que je vais vous dire c'est que
c'est ce choix là et est imputable
finalement au choix de confinement et
c'est quoi c'est qu'on a voulu protéger
les vies humaines
on a voulu protéger les vies humaines et
pour protéger les vies humaines
eh bien on a essayé de ralentir la
circulation du virus est pour ralentir
la circulation des côtes de virus on a
appris la responsabilité de ralentir
l'économie
c'est la première fois dans le monde et
c'est assez c'est positif si vous voulez
comme comme réaction parce que l'or lors
des ddd temps débit précédente
on s'était pas très beaucoup préoccuper
des dés de protéger les vies humaines on
essayait de protéger finalement l'
équilibre global de chaque moment des
épidémies de variole qui aurait ou de
rougeurs et le porte et terrifiant la
peste noire qui est même le sida vous
savez le sida il a fait 38 millions de
morts dans le monde
eh bien on n'en est pas là avec avec le
corps d'un virus donc je sais ça c'est
important et puis l'autre chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut souligner c'est que
effectivement c'est une collaboration du
monde entier dont on va avoir besoin
jean marc silvert c'est évidemment la
question que tout le monde se pose est
ce que on va pouvoir se relever de ça et
au final qui va payer
alors on va pouvoir se relever de ça si
ça ne dure pas très longtemps mais yahia
il ya quand même un point positif dans
tout ça c'est que contrairement aux
autres crise économique vous parliez de
la crise des subprimes en 2008 2009
on peut parler de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en 1940 contrairement à ces
crises là où on a perdu il n'y a pas eu
de descriptions d'actifs
les entreprises ne sont pas démoli elles
sont à l'arrêt 1
il suffit de de faire repartir le le
moteur de tourner la clé
et ça repart
l'offre potentiellement et elle peut
être pas existé les usines chinoises et
le gie procès des juges nommés
donnez moi je voudrais vous couper là
dessus parce que vous dites il suffit de
voilà de rallumer le moteur face à ça va
pour les grandes entreprises peut-être
mais mais les pme
est ce que vraiment le chômage partiel
peut les sauver réellement il y aura des
faillites le chômage partiel permet à
l'entreprise de rester en état de
fonctionner c'est à dire qui a pas de
rupture de contrat de travail c'est à
dire que demain et bien les salariés
reviennent au travail retrouvent leur
job ils retrouvent leur poste etc
mais s'il faut pas que ça dure trop
longtemps parce que évidemment le
chômage partiel
ça coûte très très cher à la
collectivité donc ça peut éventuellement
redémarrer ça peut même redémarrer très
vite mais un il faut pas que ça dure
trop longtemps parce que si ça dure trop
longtemps on va casser
évidemment le tissu des pme l'on va
aussi casser les grandes entreprises
regardez le lyrisme cours air france
aujourd'hui airbus l'automobile par
exemple on a cassé ces entreprises là
déjà en 2008 2009 on a mis dix ans à
l'aller à l'heure à leur remontée donc
il faut pas que ça dure trop longtemps
deuxièmement il faut que les procédures
de déconfinement c'est à dire de sortir
de deux sorties de cet immobilisme se
fasse dans des conditions de sécurité
sanitaire parce que on nous n'oubliez
pas que l'art est vraie raison profonde
tout ça c'est l'inquiétude au niveau de
la santé c'est que vous avez cette épée
de damoclès sur la tête et il faut
absolument les éliminer donc il faut
trouver des conditions de sécurité tout
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
c'était évidemment ce qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre et renforcé quand renforçait
le confinement renforcer les gestes qui
sait de protection renforcée le match
renforcer évidemment aussi tout tout la
traçabilité de façon à pouvoir
reconnaître ceux qui sont malades de
ceux qui ne sont pas malades ou de ceux
qui ont été malades et qui sont
immunisés c'est comme cela
progressivement qu'on sortira en terme
de sécurité et 6 4 la sécurité y aura de
la confiance et s'il ya de la confiance
est bien la machine économique repartir
quand on sait que la dette est déjà de
100% du pib
je vous repose la question qui va payer
au final est-ce que c'est l'état qui va
continuer à emprunter ou finalement
c'est vous et moi avec nos impôts
écouter de toute façon c'est vous et moi
qui paieront au final que ce soit avec
les impôts que ce soit avec des hausses
de prix ou avec de l'inflation parce que
il faudra bien qu'il y ait un
rééquilibrage
mais tout ça ça peut s'étaler dans le
temps tout ça ça peut aussi entraîner
des modifications structurelles avec
peut-être plus de productivité plus de
rentabilité de façon à ce qu'on puisse
rembourser
et tout ça je j'entendais les
difficultés que peut avoir l'europe
on oublie très souvent que l'europe
allait doter de la banque centrale
européenne et que c'est aujourd'hui la
banque centrale européenne qui assure la
mutualisation de tout ça au sein de
l'europe avec des avec des dotations en
liquidités qui sont considérables dans
le secteur dont on parle pas mais qui
est totalement sécurisée aujourd'hui et
gants en europe grâce à la banque
centrale et rentrent au mécanisme
européen c'est le secteur de la banque
vous n'avez pas une banque aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient en état de risques ou de
fragilité c'était pas le cas en 2008
en 2008 on a bien failli et un peu comme
lehman brothers avoir des problèmes de
ce côté là donc vous à vous avez quand
même une mécanique financière qui peut
absorber tout ça mais il est évident que
la vie d'après sera pas exactement comme
celle de la vie d'avant merde ce panier
d'europe justement et chacun aujourd'hui
de la réunion démunis des finances est
ce que cette action conjointe de l'union
européenne ce qu'elle est nécessaire et
est ce qu'elle va voir le jour parce que
ça me semble compliqué manifestement les
nécessaires ce qui est très compliqué
c'est de mettre en place un produit
financier qui s'appelait qui
s'appellerait leur bond ou le koro la
bonde c'est un produit dont certains
courants politiques rêvent depuis très
longtemps mais c'est un produit qui
oblige les gens qui ont de l'argent à
payer pour les gens qui n'en n'ont pas
dans un espace dans de mutualité il faut
qui est quand même un deal dans tout ça
et moi je comprends parfaitement
quelque part les allemands les
scandinaves que j'ai à dire ben on va
quand même pas on a nos
problème on viendrait à la france
demandé de régler les problèmes italien
je crois qu'on s'est pas précipité en
italie pour pour eux pour les aider et
les italiens d'ailleurs s'en souviennent
un petit peu donc ce problème de
solidarité mutualité il a d'autre moyen
que le corps abonde de passer je parlais
de la banque centrale européenne la
banque centrale européenne fait de la
mutualisation
elle en fait tous les jours et elle elle
elle distribue les liquidités aph de
face aux aspects du système fonctionne
et vous avez d'autres mécanismes de
financement qui fonctionne et qui vont
fonctionner sans parler de l'effort
personnel qui seront faites par les
différents gouvernements
des efforts qui ont été faits par les
différents gouvernements l'espagne
l'italie la la france sur décision sur
des efforts qui sont colossaux donc on
aura sans doute une réunion après pour
savoir comment on se répartit les
factures et vous savez c'est comme dans
une copropriété
c'est pas facile car il faut il aimer ça
demandera sans doute du temps mais si on
veut rester en copropriété on a intérêt
restant mobilisés parce que je vais vous
dire une chose c'est que cette affaire
de crise sanitaire
elle a montré qu'il existait quoi qu'on
dise une collaboration internationale
c'est la première fois en effet qu'on a
la connaissance international de
l'identité du virus c'est la première
fois que l'on pas très vite
c'est la première fois que dans tous les
pays on utilise à peu près on a le on a
fait le même diagnostic et on utilise à
peu près les mêmes méthodes de
redressement et je trouve que ça il n'y
a pas beaucoup de corporations henin qui
collaborent autant que les médecins et
les laboratoires de recherche
actuellement il ne peut pas se passer
quelque chose dans le monde sans que
dans le quart d'heure qui suivent le
monde entier soit au courant le vaccin
on le connaîtra il naîtra soit en france
ou en allemagne peut-être peut-être en
france et en allemagne d'ailleurs en
même temps mais il sera distribué
partout
merci beaucoup un jean marc sylvestre
journaliste éditorialiste économique
d'avoir été avec nous et ainsi avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
évidemment sur cette crise du corps d'un
virus
on va aller en suède voir un petit peu
comment ça se passe le pays non confiné
vous le savez peu à peu rattrapés lui
aussi par l'arrêt ali
direction ensuite les etats-unis où
l'état de new york est vraiment
gravement touchée avec plus de 4000
décès une tendance se dégage et donald
trump s'en est inquiété les américains
noirs sont les plus contaminés et meurt
le pouce
[Musique]
paris 2024 vos arguments messieurs êtes
vous pour ou contre
avant moi je suis tout à fait pour mais
pas n'importe quel prix il est hors de
question qu'une chance d'organiser les
jeux olympiques se transforme en une
véritable malédiction comme c'est le cas
très souvent moi je vais représenter le
contre parce que pour moi les jeux
olympiques c'est véritablement
l'expression du vieux monde c'est à dire
que qui ne prend jamais en compte la
question climatique la question sociale
la question environnementale
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer donc ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est vraiment
contrôlé au centime près jour par jour
ce budget est joué la transparence
complète tous les acteurs qu'ils soient
publics qu'ils soient privés ou on a
déjà un budget qui n'est pas n'est pas
sérieux et que oui ça veut dire que
nécessairement ça va être dépassé
paris fait beaucoup plus attention que
ses prédécesseurs aux questions vers non
seulement parce que c'est à la mode mais
aussi parce que le seuil haut c'est
quand même aperçu a senti passer le vent
du boulet
[Musique]
depuis le début de cette crise les
français sont sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique
très très fort notamment pour pour les
actifs bien évidemment plus vous êtes
âgé plus vous avez peur du réel de la
mort c'est évident les études elle
montre que oui pourquoi 30 à 40%
il y à un stress modéré il ya un stress
sévère pour à peu près 5%
on a un focus assez fort sur les
adolescents étonnamment un focus sur les
aînés également très important c'est à
dire que ceux qui résisteront le mieux
ce sont entre guillemets la classe d
actifs
est-ce que selon vous l'être humain peut
gérer une proximité quotidienne avec sa
famille comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça resserre les liens au
contraire est-ce que ça les haltères
nous devons réapprendre le goût du
comportement collectif voilà le goût un
peu d' une autodiscipline le goût du
civisme parce que si nous vivons ça
simplement comme une restriction de nos
libertés individuelles comme si nous ne
vivons pas ça comme une aventure
collective de protection solidaire des
ans a été jeune
ça va être la extraordinairement
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants de la
première heure de notre administration a
été 3 que les terroristes étaient des
loups solitaires alors qu'ils étaient la
résultante de 15 ans de travail de fond
fait par les élèves et on clair ils ont
prêché la guerre sainte et le problème
c'est qu'on les a trop longtemps laissé
il ya eu un espèce de déni de réalité et
il a fallu drame bataclan pour qu'il y
ait enfin une reconnaissance générale de
la situation dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice mme belloubet
annonce la sortie en 2020 de 43 du à 10
140 avant fin 2022 sur les 531 incarcéré
aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie de
ces individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nation
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour une deuxième heure une
demi heure précisément d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi en
france le confinement est prolongée au
delà du 15 avril annonces de l'elysée ce
soir le président macron s'exprimera
finalement lundi peu après 20 heures le
bilan on dénombre 7630 de décès en
milieu hospitalier soit 541 décès de
plus en 24 heures selon le directeur
général de la santé qui précise que ce
bilan ce soir ne concerne pas les ehpad
au royaume uni l'état de boris johnson
s'améliore mais le pays a des plans la
mort de 938 personnes de plus en 24
heures c'est un triste record
la suède qui musèle d'une stratégie à
contre-courant excluant le confinement
compte son décès de plus en 24 heures
une lueur d'espoir en italie en revanche
pays le plus endeuillé au monde par
l'épidémie qui enregistre une baisse du
nombre de morts et de malades en soins
intensifs ces dernières heures
[Musique]
plus de 80 de 1700 morts sur la planète
au total aux états unis pires bilans
quotidiens on enregistre deux mille
nouveaux cas donald trump dénonce la
gestion de la pandémie actuelle par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et l'attitude jugée trop favorable à la
chine réaction de l'om est ce qu'ils
appellent les états unis et la chine à
s'unir contre le coronavirus
[Musique]
le confinement est donc prolongée au
delà du 15 avril en france est ce que
vient d'annoncer l'elysée le président
macron s'exprimera finalement lundi peu
après 20h quant au bilan le nombre de
morts en milieu hospitalier selon grimpe
à 7600 32 soit 541 décès supplémentaires
lors des dernières 24 heures précise le
directeur général de la santé en raison
d'un problème technique qui empêchent
l'accès à l'application santé publique
france lui ne peut pas donner un bilan
des ehpad celui que ce soir ne concerne
donc que le milieu hospitalier la france
déplore à ce jour au moins dix mille
huit cent soixante neuf longueurs
3 le bilan des décès reprend donc ce
soir
la mortalité hospitalière 7630 deux
décès sont à déplorer depuis le 1er mars
82 % des décès observés surviennent chez
des personnes de plus de 70 ans
au cours des dernières 24 heures c'est
donc un total de 5 141 décès étaient
enregistrés en milieu hospitalier
enfin c'est important 21250 quatre
personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital ce chiffre continue
d'augmenter jour après jour et bien
entendu il faut y ajouter les dizaines
de milliers de personnes guéries à la
maison et qui n'ont pas eu besoin fort
heureusement d'être hospitalisée et le
corps des virus ont su elle la suède qui
change son fusil d'épaulé jusqu'à
maintenant pas de confinement et peu de
mesures restrictives
un choix assumé par les autorités mais
face à cette crise en nette progression
dans le pays le gouvernement hausse le
ton les explications en images
[Musique]
oh
tous
[Musique]
il
et pour évoquer cette stratégie adoptée
en suède face au co vie 19 nous sommes
en direct depuis göteborg avec stefan
aline berthe professeur en sciences
politiques à l'université de göteborg
directeur de vdm institude c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir je taf anna lindh merci d'être
avec nous en direct par téléphone sur
rtl france le rythme de la mortalité qui
dépensent maintenant on dépasse
maintenant en suède les 100 personnes
toutes les 24 heures 700 personnes au
total sont mortes en suède c'est une
beaucoup un pour un pays de 10 millions
d'habitants est ce que les suédois tout
d'abord son inquiet commence à prendre
vraiment la mesure de la crise
colling bonsoir à tous je pense que les
autorités suédoises constat est que le
gouvernement a su et toi autant que je
puisse le tiers font confiance au
gouvernement et aux autorités sanitaires
alors il n'empêche
effectivement les chiffres ne sont pas
très bons alors certains
épidémiologistes suédois défendre le
bilan de la suède
on rappelle qui est à contre-courant pas
de mesures de confinement école ouverte
même si on appelle évidemment respecter
les gestes barrière
est ce qu'on ne peut pas dire quand même
aujourd'hui que c'est une stratégie qui
montre ses limites
je ne suis pas épidémiologistes donc je
ne veux pas m'exprimer sur la pertinence
de certaines mesures
ce que je sais c'est une situation
vraiment innover car tous les pays et
chaque pays fait des expériences
trouvent les mesures pertinentes
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que en europe et
dans le monde avec un plus de nombreux
pays ont adopté des mesures très
strictes les droits politiques
les libertés civiques la libération de
tous leurs citoyens
les citoyens demandent que d'efforts
dirigeants les sourds de cette crise
c'est une tendance très importante pour
moi cela me rappelle ce que l'on a vu
dans les années 1940
de plus sans conséquences de ces mesures
nous allons avoir des dizaines de
millions de personnes en europe et dans
le monde qui vont perdre leur emploi
leurs revenus affichent à leur assurance
santé
cela va avoir des conséquences ça va
aussi coûter des vies donc il s'agit
également de sauver des vies et de
sauver la première politique
vous êtes effectivement raccord avec les
choix de en tout cas des autorités
suédoises
ça veut dire qu'en gros c'est peut-être
pire de stopper totalement une économie
qu'on tue autant peut-être avec une amy
une économie totalement à plat que ne le
fait le virus c'est en résumé notre
propos
il a effectivement non ce que je veux
dire c'est que nous ne savons pas mais
nous savons que la dépression et le
chômage de masse ont des conséquences
sociales ont un coût humain ne savons
pas combien il va y avoir des morts et
c'est très grave et il faut absolument
étudie l'équilibré à trouver au marché
je ne quittais pas les mesures adoptées
au suggérée par les épidémiologistes en
suède ou en france chaque pièce est
unique y est et doit gérer la crise en
fonction de ses caractéristiques du
tradition culture meilleures normes
spécifiques
je pense que la stratégie en suède a
montré de bons résultats bon je ne suis
pas un expert
cependant ce qui m'a fait assez que l'on
voit l'apparition d'une dictature et
cela apparaîtra également dans d'autres
endroits dans le monde
la dictature a des effets très néfastes
sur le monde sur les vies humaines sur
les familles s'opposent
nous devons rester concentrés
mais pas seulement sur la lutte contre
l'épidémie mais également sur les
conséquences que pourrait être homme
impliqué par certaines mesures et les
mesures doivent être bons pérenne et
durable
je ne sais pas combien de temps en
france on acceptera d'être confiné oui
je sais la montagne il ya beaucoup de
tension qu'au royaume-uni également des
tensions commencent à apparaître
quelles que soient les mesures adoptées
devraient rester conscients du fait que
nous sommes des démocraties libre et
qu'il faut nous défendre stephen neal
baer qu'est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à
estimer que certains gouvernements se
serviraient peut-être de cette crise
sanitaire pour voilà aller vers une
restriction des libertés
et individuel vous parliez de dictature
en gris vous pensez qu'il ya parfois une
arrière pensée de la part de certains
gouvernements de profiter entre
guillemets de la situation de la fratrie
oui on va nous avons déjà pu le
constater par exemple effectivement cela
ne fait aucun doute même si vous ou moi
ou quelqu'un qui nous écoutent
souhaitait devenir dictateur un pays
soumis démocrate alors cette pandémie
serait tu me rendes occasion véritable
chance ce que l'on sait que l'allemagne
ne des remarques et beaucoup d'autres
pays et font pour elle c'est une bonne
chose parce que on peut dire eh bien ces
autres pays on monte également confiner
leurs citoyens il ya la police dans les
rues là bas aussi qui empêche les gens
de se déplacer en italie il ya l'armée
dans les rues
nous faisons que la même chose cela
n'arrive pas seulement mon cri c'est
l'art étant bien d'autres pays
en plus de toutes les morts on a viré ça
il y aura beaucoup de morts dus à eau
perte des libertés
merci beaucoup staff and line berck
professeur en sciences politiques à
l'université de göteborg d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france nous avoir
apporté votre point de vue vous parliez
justement de l'italie pays le plus
endeuillé d'europe on enregistre 17
mille décès mais le pic est passé
semble-t-il on observe une baisse de
décès de contamination et de patients en
soins intensifs
les autorités italiennes restent tout de
même évidemment prudente elle continue
de multiplier les appels au respect des
règles de confinement en ville
moi jusqu'au 13 avril attention nous qui
vont être qu'au début d'une longue
transition
il serait impardonnable de cesser
d'imposer ces restrictions rendant ainsi
inutile les sacrifices que nous avons
consentis ces derniers jours et le
royaume uni quant à lui en registre un
triste record de décès en 24 heures 938
mans lors des derniers la dernière
journée au total plus de 7000 décès
outre manche une situation évidemment
très inquiétantes quant à boris johnson
son état s'améliore selon le ministre
des finances ce soir positif au coït 19
depuis le 27 mars
il a été hospitalisé dimanche en plat et
placé en soins intensifs
je suis sûr que les gens voudront
également être informés de l'évolution
de l'état de santé du premier ministre
il reçoit d'excellents soins de la part
de l'équipe médicale à saint thomas
les dernières nouvelles de l'hôpital
sont que le premier ministre reste en
soins intensifs où son état s'améliore
je peux également vous dire qu'ils
s'assoient dans son lit et qu'il
communique positivement avec l'équipe
clinique aux états unis la barre des 400
jeunes milk a été dépassée on y
enregistre près de 13000 mort l'état de
new york est le plus lourd tribut et
enregistre un nouveau record de décès au
coronavirus ces dernières 24 heures avec
779 morts en plus reportage à new york
de clarisse riotord avec le récit de
clémence pital
manhattan comme on ne l'a jamais vu ces
russes en voiture ses trottoirs sans
piétons c'est dans une atmosphère
pesante que new york vit sa troisième
semaine de confinement la maison blanche
a demandé samedi dernier à tous les
américains d'éviter les supermarchés
pharmacie durant les deux prochaines
semaines
on est en train de faire la queue juste
pour rentrer dans le supermarché parce
qu'il n'autorise pas plus de 50
personnes à la fois cette files
d'attentes et juste pour nous permettre
d'aller acheter à manger
oui en plus c'était pire pour nous ce
matin pire d'ici et là files d'attentes
faisait le tour du magasin
c'est fou et en plus certains disent
qu'on ne pourra pas faire des courses
pour les 15 prochains jours alors on
essaie de prendre autant de choses que
possible pour ne pas avoir à revenir
dans le bronx l'armée prête main forte à
ceux qui ne peuvent sortir
s'approvisionner
les soldats prépare des cartons de
nourriture qui sont ensuite confiés à
des chauffeurs chargé d'assurer la
livraison
bien sûr dans des temps comme celui ci
notre famille a vraiment peur pour nous
mais ce sont pour eux que nous sommes
ici dehors à travailler et lutter pour
la sécurité et assurer le bien-être de
tous beaucoup de new yorkais craignent
d'avoir contracté le kovy de 10,9
rebecca elle aussi éprouvé des
difficultés respiratoires de la fièvre
et une toux incontrôlable il ya deux
semaines dépourvu de mutuelles de santé
la jeune styliste n'a pas pu se faire
dépister a new yorkaise qui a perdu son
travail à cause de la pandémie s'est
donc mise à confectionner des masques
les gens ont commencé à me demander si
je fabriquer des masques et puis je
connais plusieurs personnes qui
travaillent dans la santé
ma soeur est infirmière et ça me touche
vraiment de savoir qu'ils n'ont pas
assez de protection d'équipements et de
masques
alors j'ai commencé à en fabriquer et
même s'ils vont principalement à la
famille et aux amis
au moins je peux apporter mon aide new
york se débat avec son triste statut
d'épicentre de l'épidémie de kovy dix
neuf aux états unis cet état compte
ainsi près de la moitié des douze mille
morts comptabilisés dans le pays et plus
d'un tiers des cas de contamination
elle donne en train pluie s'en prend à
l'om est ce le président américain juge
l'organisation mondiale de santé trop
clémente à l'égard de pékin ils menacent
de suspendre la contribution de
washington à l'organisation se sont
trompés ils auraient pu avertir des mois
plus tôt il l'aurait su ils auraient dû
le savoir il ne savait probablement donc
nous allons examiner sous la très
attentivement et nous allons mettre
arrivé en dépenses de l' oms nous allons
mettre un frein très puissant à ses
dépenses et nous allons voir une bonne
chose si ça marche mais ils disent
toujours que c'est mauvais ce n'est pas
bon toujours aux états unis les patients
atteints du comique 19 ne sont pas tous
égaux face à la maladie dans plusieurs
régions du pays l'épidémie
tu de façon disproportionnée notamment
la communauté afro-américaine de
multiples responsables réclament la
publication de statistiques nationales
afin de comprendre l'ampleur du
phénomène
selon yvonne hilton un anesthésiste au
centre médical de l'université de
virginie ce n'était pas quelque chose de
nouveau at il dit nous savons que les
afro-américains en moins de chances
d'être testé moins de chances d'être
admis à l'hôpital moins de ressources
disponibles à grande échelle
ce n'est pas quelque chose de nouveau et
donc lorsque vous avez une pénurie de
tests disponibles
alors ces populations ciblées vont
encore plus risqué d'être privé du même
accès aux soins que tout le monde
lorsque vous avez un système qui ne
soigne pas ces personnes de statut
social et économique plus bas et ses
minorités elles ne sont pas testés elles
sont renvoyées chez elles au sein de
leur communauté et ses travailleurs qui
sont maintenant infecté vont dans les
supermarchés et lorsque les couches
supérieures de l'amérique iront faire
leurs courses
elles seront elles aussi affectées et
pour parler de ce phénomène nous sommes
en direct avec taoufik jebali maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine l
université de caen auteur de minorités
et pouvoir dans les pays anglophones aux
éditions l'harmattan
bonsoir à toufik chebani merci d'être
avec nous est ce que ce constat un
chiffre édifiant concernant la
population afro-américaine et ces
chiffres voilà qui prouve qu'ils sont
plus touchés par le virus est ce que ça
vous surprend
en fait ça me surprend ça ne me surprend
pas du tout du tout vu la situation déjà
dans laquelle se trouvaient les
afro-américains bien avant la pandémie
qui sévit partout dans le monde
donc en fait le problème des
afro-américains est un problème tout à
ses anciens et en relation
essentiellement avec le soin et les
soins médicaux alors c'est
essentiellement des causes sociales
l'invité précédent qu'on entendait
enregistré en tout cas parler de pénurie
de tests qui concernaient principalement
cette population pour quelles raisons
tout d'abord c'est lié en premier lieu
je crois au système de soin aux etats
unis c'est un système à deux vitesses
ceux qui ont les moyens d'avoir une
assurance ils ont accès à des soins de
qualité
ceux qui sont pauvres il y a un
programme qui s'appelle medicaid
mais qui donne accès à un minimum de
soins et ceux qui n'ont pas d'assurance
qui ne sont qui ne sont ni pauvre as dit
assez je dirais pauvres pour avoir accès
à ce programme fédéral medicaid
ils ne sont pas assez riches pour se
payer une assurance privée
donc il se trouve entre les deux et donc
ils ne bénéficient pas de d'une
couverture médicale ces gens là ils sont
essentiellement des minorités et je
dirais des afro américains
donc il ya la question elle est très
très profondes liées au système médical
américain
il a énormément de déficiences dans ce
système il ya énormément de problèmes
obama avec sa réforme de 2010 n'a pas pu
complètement résoudre le problème il ya
une résistance à la fois des lobbys une
résistance d'une partie de la population
une partie privilégiée et du coup on se
trouve avec un système qui de toute
façon ne regarde que ceux qui ont de
l'argent
du coup évidemment les afro-américains
qui représente grosso modo 30 pour 13%
de la population
il représente non à peu près 30% des
pauvres ça veut dire que c'est une
population extrêmement pauvre par
rapport à d'autres communautés et du
coup elle se trouve à la marge de la
société à la marge
bien entendu du système médical
américain donc il y à une question
d'argent qui est une question centrale
dans le système médical américain et les
noirs américains les afro américains se
trouvent complètement marginal
c'est par rapport à ce système qui de
toute façon est un système de jeu plus
un hôpital américain et les là
essentiellement pour faire pour se faire
de l'argent donc il y avait non une
machine à sous qui est qui est là et pas
un hôpital qui au service de la
population
agrican on parle beaucoup des afro
américains qu'en est il des hispaniques
sachant au passage que c'est vrai qu'on
parle de ses minorités
ça veut dire que les états unis dispose
de statistiques ethniques
effectivement tout d'abord par rapport à
ce virus le coronavirus il n'y a pas de
statistiques nationales et ça a été dit
dans votre reportage
donc il n'ya pas de statistiques
fédérales jusqu'à maintenant il ya des
appels à ce que on arrive à avoir une
vue d'ensemble sur ce problème
on a des chiffres on a dit statistique
sur le plan de l'état ont sur le temps
ou sur le haut sur le plan de la ville
ou de comptes et donc quelque part c'est
c'est un problème extrêmement sérieux
ça veut dire que le gouvernement fédéral
n'a même pas vraiment de trace n'a pas
de chiffre crédible sur la question des
minorités par rapport aux espagnols
effectivement et ce en plus proche sur
le plan sociologique sur le plan social
et je dis et si je dirais plutôt par
rapport à des critères par rapport à des
indicateurs économiques qui sont plus
proches de la communauté noire que de la
communauté blanche
il se trouve julie rey entre les deux
mais ils sont par rapport à ces chiffres
là les chiffres par rapport aux
hispaniques ne sont pas aussi dramatique
pour que pour le la communauté afro
américaine
donc ils sont défavorisés par le système
est encore plus quand il s'agit de
quelques millions d'hispaniques qui se
trouvent en dehors pratiquement de
l'administration américaine des
statistiques de l'administration
week-end on parle de 12 millions grosso
modo de 12 millions de clandestins
essentiellement d'espagne et des
hispaniques
donc ces gens là ils sont en effet à la
marge de la société
mais il faut savoir aussi que les
espagne représente
c'est la deuxième c'est la plus grande
minorité américaine 6 2 16% de la
population
cette population elle souffre et elle va
souffrir énormément je dirais pas
peut-être pas autant que les afro
américains
mais le problème est sérieux et sans
fortement impactés par ce problème et je
dirais que l'art avec les afro
américains s'avouent constitué vraiment
les laissés pour compte de ce système à
la fois médicale et je serai
certainement les premières victimes de
ce virus et de cette pandémie
taoufik jebali clairement est ce que
vous craignez particulièrement aux
etats-unis une catastrophe sanitaire
sans précédent
sachant vous l'avez expliqué un que le
système de santé
est ce qu'il est un plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de dollars pour un malade du
coc vite sachant qu'ils n'ont pas tous
une couverture et kylie a énormément de
chômage est ce qu'il ya une énorme
inquiétude à avoir pour les états unis
plus qu'ailleurs moi je pense que pour
les états unis ça va être un sérieux
problème
tout d'abord il ya une question
politique derrière tout ça c'est que
trempe au début n'a pas pris les choses
au sérieux et donc il a fallu vraiment
que la catastrophe touche des états
comme new york ou la californie pour que
donald trump se réveille je dirais et
donc pour qu'ils prennent les choses au
sérieux et qu'il intervienne
pratiquement aujourd'hui on le voit tous
les jours devant les caméras de la
télévision pour expliquer sa démarche
donc il ya une écoute une inquiétude
réelle on arrive à des chiffres mais a à
l'incident sur cette catastrophe
je pense qu'on n'est pas encore je dire
excusez moi l'expression sorti de
l'auberge
il va y avoir énorme
de dégâts c'est ce n'est juste que ce
n'est que le début et que le problème va
toucher d'autres endroits que new york
est que l'amérique elle est complètement
démunis là les fautes à les partager par
pas mal de soi par l'état fédéré soit
par l'état fédéral
mais il va y avoir pas mal de problèmes
et j'ai personnellement je m'inquiète
énormément de problèmes delà de ce qui
va se passer aux états unis les états
unis vu le système l'éthique vue là la
tradition où je dirais vu le système
médical aux états unis
je crains le pire pour les américains et
surtout évidemment par rapport au jeu je
parle ici par rapport aux pauvres est
une folie à plus de 32 40 millions de
pauvres par rapport aux afro-américains
par rapport aux minorités laval ça va
avoir énormément de dégâts merci
beaucoup
taoufik djebel jozan prix merci à vous
on l'a appris ce soit bernie sanders
suspend sa campagne en vue de la
présidentielle américaine la campagne se
termine
la lutte continue peut-on lire dans le
communiqué publié par le candidat
socialiste de son côté joe biden son
ancien rival apels les partisans de
sanders au rassemblement écouter celui
donc qui jette l éponge
j'aimerais pouvoir vous donner de
meilleures nouvelles mais je pense que
vous connaissez la vérité à savoir qu'il
y a maintenant trois cents délégués
derrière le vice président biden et que
le chemin de la victoire est
pratiquement impossible
ainsi alors que nous gagnons la bataille
idéologique et alors que nous gagnons le
soutien de tant de jeunes et de
travailleurs dans tout le pays et j'ai
conclu que cette bataille pour
l'investiture démocratique ne sera pas
couronné de succès c'est pourquoi
j'annonce aujourd'hui la suspension de
ma campagne
sachez que je ne prends pas cette
décision à la légère il s'agit en fait
d'une décision très difficile et
douloureuse c'est la fin de cette
émission un peu écourtée vous le savez
en raison de la crise du coronavirus et
comme tous les moyens nous sommes
contraints de ring
ir nos programmes pour un con paix sur
l'actualité ce sera demain matin 9
heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
paris 2024 vos arguments messieurs êtes
vous pour ou contre
a voir je suis tout à fait pour mais pas
n'importe quel prix et il est hors de
question qu'une chance d'organiser les
jeux olympiques se transforme